we are told triangle a prime b prime c
prime is the image of triangle abc under
a dilation whose center is p and scale
factor is three fourths
which figure correctly shows triangle a
prime b prime c prime using the solid
line so pause this video and see if you
can figure this out on your own
all right now before i even look at the
choices i like to just think about what
would that dilation actually look like
so our center of dilation is p and it's
a scale factor of 3 4. so one way to
think about it is however far any point
was from p before it's not going to be
three fourths as far
but along the same line
so i'm just going to estimate it so if c
was there three half would be this way
far so three fourths would be right
about there so c prime should be about
there
if we have this line connecting b
and p
like this
three let's see half of that is there
three fourths is going to be there so b
prime should be there and then on this
line
halfway is roughly there i'm just
eyeballing it so three fourths is there
so a prime
a prime should be there
and so
a prime b prime c prime should look
something
like
this
which we can see
is exactly what we see for choice c so
choicey it looks correct so i'm going to
just circle that or or select it just
like that but let's just make sure we
understand why these other two choices
were not correct
so choice a
it looks like it is a dilation with a 3
4 scale factor each of the dimensions
each of the sides of these triangles of
this triangle looks like it's about 3 4
of what it originally was but it doesn't
look like the center of dilation is p
here the center of dilation looks like
it is probably the midpoint
between or the midpoint of segment ac
because now it looks like everything is
3 4 of the distance it was to that point
so they have they have this other center
of dilation in choice a the center of
dilation is not p and that's why we can
rule that one out
and then for choice b right over here it
looks like they just got the scale
factor on actually they got the center
of dilation and the scale factor wrong
it still looks like they're they are
using this as a center of dilation but
this scale factor looks like it's much
closer to one-fourth or one-third not
three-fourths so that's why we can rule
that one out as well we like our choice
e